the term escrow let me that he looked
funny
the term escrow is used a lot in real
estate it's actually used in a lot of
just financial transactions in general
but real estate is the place that most
of us will see it most frequently and
even in the context of residential real
estate it tends to be used in two
different ways which can only make it
more confusing now one way in which the
word escrow is used is when you're
actually buying the house so what
happens is you make an offer on the
house let's say that the seller accepts
the offer then you have an opening of
escrow and what an escrow is it's a
third party account so it's a it's
managed by a trusted third party so this
right over here is escrow escrow and
it's managed by a trusted a trusted
third party and what happens is is that
the buyer we do the buyer in a another
color the buyer places all of their
obligations into escrow so it might be
the deposit that was part of the offer
contract it could be the actual the
remainder of the down payment usually
the deposit goes towards the down
payment it could be it could be getting
the financing so let's this is the down
payment the down payment and the deposit
it could be getting actually securing
the financing which would mean the
remainder of the house and the seller
fulfills all of their obligations so
this right over here is the seller and
they allow the house to be inspected and
let's say that the house passes
inspection passes inspection let's say
that the title company is able to do a
title search and it's a clear title
clear title clear title so then on the
closing day and that day is actually the
closing of escrow so you go to the
closing day so closing on the closing
day this third party says okay everybody
has met their obligations I am going to
give the seller the money I'm going to
give the seller the money
I'm going to give the buyer I'm going to
give the buyer the house or we could say
the title the title to the house and we
go into a lot more depth into this in
other video so this is one form of
escrow it's that third party where all
of the the things from either party are
put into place so that you can have
closing and then actually and actually
transact the house and the title of the
money and the house actually changes
hands now the other way that the word
escrow is used in residential real
estate it's a related idea it still
involves having a trusted third party
and that's what this term generally
means it's using a trusted third party
having a trusted third party account
where the different parties to a
transaction they can use it so that they
can facilitate the transaction itself so
the other place you might see this is
actually when you are making your
mortgage payments so when we typically
talk about mortgage payments let's say
that your monthly mortgage is let's just
say for the sake of simplicity it's
$1,000
it's $1,000 so this is your mortgage
payment $1,000 and let's say your very
first mortgage payment is going to have
some amount of it is going to be paying
for interest so when you start paying it
so we're going to be mainly interest and
some of it is to pay down principal
principal and then we've seen this a lot
of times the next payment of $1,000 if
you have a fixed mortgage so the next
payment of $1,000 more of it is going to
be principal and less of it is going to
be interest but when you actually write
your check to the bank you might find
out that you're paying more than $1,000
and you say why am i paying more than
$1,000 and if you call your bank and you
would ask them that they said okay well
you know what if you're not able to pay
this mortgage this house comes to us and
we want to make sure that this house is
properly insured and we want to make
sure that the taxes are paid on it why
do they care that the house is insured
well if if the house isn't insured and
there's a hurricane or a tornado and it
destroys the house then you might want
to walk away from that mortgage and all
the house and all the banks going to be
left with is a house that was destroyed
by a hurricane or tornado so they want
it to be insured and they also want the
taxes to be paid because once again if
there's a bunch of back taxes you might
just walk away from the house and then
the bank is going to be left paying
those back
taxes and so what the bank might do is
say okay you know what you your house
and I'm just going to fix the numbers so
that the so that they work out well for
your house you have to pay twelve
hundred twelve hundred a year in
insurance in insurance and you have to
pay and you have to pay twelve hundred a
year twelve hundred year in property
taxes in taxes so that comes to a total
of twenty four hundred a year whoops
that comes to a total of 2,400 2,400 a
year and so and we could write this for
this is for taxes and insurance and
sometimes I'll leave in the shorthand T
and I so there's a twenty four hundred
dollars of taxes insurance the way that
we're going to make sure that you pay it
is that every month you're going to pay
1/12 of this so you're going to pay two
hundred dollars so every month you're
going to pay two hundred dollars for
taxes and insurance and this is going to
go into an escrow account so that two
hundred dollars every month goes into an
escrow account for taxes and insurance
it goes to an escrow account and then
the escrow the escrow account in this
situation whoever is managing it well
every time that they get a bill for the
taxes or insurance they will pay it out
of the escrow account and so once again
it's kind of a safe third party account
for a stated purpose and in this case
the stated purpose is to pay the
insurance and taxes to you want that to
go into that account to make sure that
the bank just doesn't pocket it and the
bank wants to go into that account so
make sure that there's money around to
pay for the insurance and taxes so these
are the two primary ways that you might
encounter the term escrow they both they
both are representing the same idea of
kind of putting money into an account
that can be used for a stated purpose
but they are usually used in two
different context here this is to
facilitate the closing of a house is
literally the closing of escrow to the
transaction of the house this is to make
sure that other costs are being paid